good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day a great day here at the toast a
great day really no matter where you are
universally beloved day I feel like they
love
I feel like
they love Wednesday like even in the in
the most dire of circumstances you know
you're a prisoner at Guantanamo but it's
Wednesday
the thing about hump day though is that
like it's Wednesday which is actually a
sucky day well excuse me for trying to
put a positive spin on a long car ride
yeah no you're excused but let's lest we
not forget like it's the middle of the
week we're getting over them but we're
getting you over the hump but you know
we we talk a lot about the perks of hump
day and I don't think we talk about the
negatives good enough Jackie don't start
because that's just a slippery slope you
know I don't think we talk about the
negatives enough I know this hump day
doesn't feel like a regular Wednesday
because the rest of our week is like for
cocked for cocked yeah it feels like a
Wednesday for me because like it sucks
and it looks so ugly like I'm doing no
hair no makeup on the toast but it's
because I got a spray tan and I'm about
to get on a flight and honestly like I
just couldn't do it you know yeah you're
playing a Chris Appleton it's like such
a crazy Brave thing to do like to be on
this YouTube channel that millions of
people see hourly
and to be looking like your most
borderline natural self like I deserve
seriously a purple heart I'm so brave no
you're fine like you're skinny in your
tan so it's fine also it's not like your
makeup
it's not like me if I come on without
makeup I don't have eyebrows and I don't
have eyelashes and I have no color in my
face like you have a face no I I see how
you could see that the face and you have
a tan and you're you're like Ava you're
a move thank God for the tan let's just
let's leave it there yeah although it
was just an absolute Delight to like
roll out of bed like a man this morning
like I literally took a shower because I
had to wash off my sprayer man I put on
some deodorant I threw my hair back and
I put on clothes like what a life yeah
what a [__] life the luxury yeah the
privilege I got to like lay around for
like an extra 20 minutes
loved every minute of it
do you think that that splits in your
future manliness no no that's that's a
good question I think perhaps what might
be in my future is you know more podcast
only days because when we're not on
YouTube we don't have to get all you
know glamorous gussied up
so honestly like I'm jealous of the
people who just have podcasts you know I
know we could be but then they don't
have ourselves so much time and money
money on makeup if we just did a podcast
makeup on this studio oh yeah this we've
already discussed that and that's why
it's so important that you subscribe to
our YouTube channel because the more
subscribers we have the less likelihood
we'll ever go podcast only permanently
but no we're definitely not going
podcast only permanently we
come this far and our Clips are now
videos
it wasn't when we started it this way
but even if we were just podcasters we
probably would have had to get on the
video train sometime this year yeah and
that would have been overwhelming yeah
like to have to do it all at once start
wearing makeup to work and being on
camera and setting up a studio you know
the clips with the clips giveth the
clips also taketh away you mean because
our Clips aren't what doing what they
used to do
no because the clips like you know are
changing our business everyone's like
falling in love with us on Tick Tock and
reels but we have to get all gussied up
oh that's what they're taking they're
taking away you know chipping away the
you know pieces of my soul got it I
thought you meant because like when we
first started posting Clips like it was
just so much fanfare no and now we're
really like claw like no that's just not
true our Clips are still killing it I
don't know what happens on Tick Tock but
I know what I see on reels on reels
they're killing it like don't come for
the clips oh my God
the clips not only are they a
quarterstone of this business they are
near and dear to my heart so yeah say
something negative about the clips
you're basically saying something
negative about me I literally didn't say
anything negative about that you said
that they're not popping off but that
could just be the algorithm not the
clips themselves the so like the fact
that you would come for the clips like
this early in the morning when I'm not
wearing makeup but I'm not coming for
the clips and also if I'm coming for the
clips I'm coming for myself I would say
like coming for the eclipse is like 50
coming for myself but it's really like
like 15 you know how I feel about the
clips like the clips are like you okay
ready
the clips to me is like rolled to you
does that kind of put it in perspective
yeah just so you can like kind of
understand where I'm coming from so on
Sunday are you celebrating Clippers day
I am
I am Monday the Sunday Mother's Day is a
really big day for me not only am I the
mother of the clips I'm the mother of
Theo and I'm kind of like a mother of
this community that's beautiful yeah
basically I don't have any children yeah
how's Theo great question I haven't seen
him in so long he is at his my in-laws
his grandparents where he honestly
prefers to spend his time when we were
in Nashville and then I came back Sunday
and I was leaving again today I was like
why disturb Theo he's so happy they take
him to the beach he has his routine so I
left him there and it's been hard I
can't lie being in my house like without
Ben and without Theo
truly not a life worth living it's so
empty and lonely that is really empty
it's that's why I've been spending so
much time with you not to rub it in but
I slept with shy San last night and
usually sleeps towards the end of the
bed because that's where I put heating
powder that's where like his favorite
Barefoot dreams blanket is but last
night when I got into bed like he just
decided to like sleep in my spot so I I
went to Zach's spot and I sat there and
like we were together the whole night
yeah no I have slept with Bruno
um many times and I can tell you it's
one of the most unpleasant experiences
last night he maybe when you have to
know how to sleep around the stripes no
I think when your baby boy is at my
house he feels like a little displaced
because he's not with his mama and he
just wants to curl up to like the
warmest thing so he has to sleep like in
my vagina he gives me no room to breathe
yeah sometimes in the night like I wind
up on my back
um I usually sleep on my side at the
side when you're pregnant like you it's
best to sleep on your side but sometimes
you know you roll over things happen and
I sleep on my back and like with my if
my legs are even like a little bit open
separated Streisand's in the middle did
you know that Megan Maroney song this is
literally about Bruno I sleep on my sad
and you sleep with everyone I don't
that's not the right Melody I've only
heard it a few times but that's
literally stress
sure I was actually listening to the
Megan moroney album this morning finding
new me
in some of the lyrics like Trader Joe
she's saying like she's a traitor Joe
trade her Joe you know grammar's so
important it always and then of course
it's like Trader Joe's let's get
groceries but you once pointed out to me
like the importance of a comma do you
remember this when oh put me in coach
put me in coach put me in coach yeah two
different meanings one you want to get
in the game the other you want to sit in
the economy right and trust and believe
if I'm ever saying put me in coach I
want to go to the field because I don't
want to sit and Coach but you want to
get in the game if I had to choose
between the two yeah I'd like to get in
the game hmm you're looking stunning
today I am just kind of Stunting Like
you knew I was gonna look ugly so you
had to look nice I do the exact same
makeup every single day I feel like
you're wearing this colorful sweater oh
yeah I got a new curd again and when I
felt like I was an old curd again that's
like I think what she was trying to say
when she wrote that song yeah she was
and this is not an old cardigan this is
a new cardigan it's nice and Pliny and
when I felt like I was a new card again
exactly new cardigan new you new
cardigan greater than old cardigan um
[Music]
sometimes an old cardigan that like has
been with you it's like in your family
for years morph to your shape and it has
memories it has like you know like holes
and stuff but that's what makes it like
important then you like wrap it around
yourself when you're staring off into
the distance on your porch contemplating
divorce you know that's like Cardigans
are made for contemplation
um you don't agree well they were also
made for pregnant women right now yeah
but like if you're not just like
wrapping the cardigan and like thinking
why bother wearing a cardigan because
you're cold because you want to cover
your arms because you want to cover your
booty because you want to cover your
arms that's really all you need you want
to cover your sides yeah no another
thing about a Cardigans are so versatile
that's why I keep asking you to bring me
some [__] Cardigans and I keep
telling you just come over to my [__]
house oh yeah now I'm gonna go shopping
in your closet but you're never home
the life of a jet-setting star so you
and the Satchel yeah are off to Dallas
can you believe I'm spending like a week
with Satchel it's literally one night
but okay it's two nights [__] and
that's exactly what a weekend is you
said A week oh I meant a weekend
um can you believe like do you think
Katie Maloney's gonna feel weird that
I'm spending like a good amount of time
with Satchel no I think she trusts you
yeah around this actually Satchel
implicitly are they still together I
really don't know okay well Vanderpump
Rules is on tonight that's exciting but
let's talk about your your 48 hours with
the satch I'm heading to Dallas today
tomorrow
Academy of Country Music Awards snatch
and I are walking the carpet we're doing
some carpet interviews we're going
inside the show and then we're gonna hit
up an after party it's gonna be like a
crazy day end
this is subject to change but I think
I'm wearing my hair up which is she is
wearing her hair up she has to if you
thought this was Brave you know coming
on this YouTube channel that millions of
people see hourly with no makeup and no
hair
just wait till you see me on the carpet
tomorrow and up to but we've established
that updos are greater than they are but
like you know it's just crazy I'm using
a local Dallas hairstylist who I'm not
I'm sure she's amazing you know Margo's
used her before but it's not someone I'm
like you know super comfortable with and
hair to me is just so personal more
personal than comedy yeah you just have
to kind of let some of your walls down
you're like making everything such a big
deal in your mind it's like girly swirly
you're wearing your hair up you're just
snatched what's the problem I can't I
can't like my walls they protect me you
know they protected me for years I know
but you have to let them down I can't
you're like just holding on to all of
this anxiety this trauma anxiety I'm
gonna try I'm really gonna try just let
the chips fall where they may how scary
is that it's fine like it's literally
fine it's fine
it's fine you've like put in all the
work I'm putting like a lot of pressure
on this up to like I think that's a
mistake I know I agree because then I'm
just gonna hate it regardless yeah like
what up to could be that perfect so true
like I just think like she's gonna spin
me around in the chair and I'm gonna be
Margot Robbie but like I just think you
should get in the chair be like do your
worst no no no no no no no but like the
whole thing together is gonna look
really nice like try not to hyper focus
and just have fun
that's just not something I'm good at
hyper focusing like not hyper focusing
and then just like having fun
just have a cocktail that probably like
is the right decision yeah just one of
course I don't need to be like sloppy on
the carpet like grabbing everyone's ass
but you would do that regardless
if you've seen our red carpet life
you know they have a twinge of unhingy
she's kind of like cheating on me in her
red card um I'm like part of another Duo
now but let me just say nothing compares
to Jackson Claude do you feel like
you're have a different personality or
like role in your other duo with snitch
yes what do you feel like it is it feels
like I am like very much like bossy and
in control like I am bossy with you but
like I feel very comfortable like we
really split everything like 50 50 in
terms of like management and like you
know the statue is just the satch and I
feel like protective and I want to like
do everything for her no but I mean like
when you're live yeah when you're doing
the
the hosting yeah do you feel like you
have a different personality Dynamic
when you're with her personality yes
because I'm the older sister now so it's
like I get to be like ah you know like I
know but I hear you're just like a
Wallflower yeah and I'm just like okay
Jax whatever you say
whereas with Margo like I'm in charge
[__] move over I'm the older sister and
like what I say goes which honestly is
very scary there's a lot of pressure
people say like oh I wish I had more say
I wish I could make more decisions it's
like okay you live with it no I do
generally like to defer to you on like
decision making so it really doesn't
affect me in any way and let's be honest
like when I'm with Margo and there's a
decision to make like I will just be
texting you so
[Laughter]
it's really like you're there God you
know but I'm excited to watch you girls
do your thing me too we'll be on the
Amazon fashion Snapchat so make sure to
find us there we're gonna be looking
fashionable too yeah I'm excited to see
the look I'm also wearing a dress that's
like kind of crazy and different you
know because it's actually it is like a
little not me in terms of style it's
because it's very feminine it's very
feminine it's very country it's got bows
like that's just not me you know me I'm
like gonna wear black
There It Is Well it's white but there's
a little block too yeah yeah no but it
is it's very girly swirly yeah it's like
very cutesy little ladybug yeah when I'm
used to dressing like a mammoth you know
she's a mammoth of course how would you
describe your style
whatever looks best like I really I
don't discriminate like it's not like I
want to go boho like oh does a boho look
good great oh the classic looks good
that's why I feel like you're in this
transition period with your shopping and
your fashion because you're realizing
that not like you have choices well
that's the other thing now I'm and I
talked about this I feel like a lot
every time I did like a patreon try on
Vlog like I really struggled like
because if something fit I was just over
the past in the past I was just gonna
keep it I was gonna wear it like it fits
like it's so hard to shop really at any
size but like in the bigger sizes like
there's such limited options for you and
then like when you do find something
that fits it might not even be the most
flattering or the most beautiful but
like you just feel compelled to wear it
because it fits right now I'm at the
phase where like multiple things fit but
I really do still find myself like
being drawn towards the same like Styles
because they still have the same problem
areas like I still have a really big
fupa so the same Styles you mean like
Silhouettes Silhouettes Silhouettes okay
like you know a rouged belly I'll never
turn away I'll never turn away a rouged
item like rouged is so that's your style
rich
ask a question again charity Lou how
would you describe
uh because I like it
so we've got a great show it's Wednesday
we've got stories describe the stories
for us Jax um a little bit of everything
a little bit one hits harder than the
other I would say like each are
contributing their 20 to the Fast Five
Oh my God not me having a dream about
Matt Healy like we were boyfriend or
girlfriend and like it was
it was hot like we were we were vibing
like you know we're two artists someone
described us as you know both tortured
artists and we had a lot in common and
Taylor wasn't even a factor but it's
like that's my level of delusion like
how much I like a pit in the dream like
that it was Taylor's man sometimes like
if I'm in a dream and like there's like
a Hawkeye or something like a celebrity
that like I'm in love with I always have
a pit I'm like oh I'm married I can't
but Taylor wasn't a factor another was
Ben in my dream and that's what he gets
for going on a business trip I'm
starting to forget about you Ben why
don't you come home
oh why didn't you come home makes you
think you know who Matt Healey reminds
me of like looks wise who mark from Ugly
Betty
you know what yes also he's in younger
he's that book agent I love that actor
love Mark from Ugly Betty who plays like
bestie of the receptionist Amanda's
bestie he's like gay and mean she's like
pretty and mean and they're just like a
mean Duo and they're so funny and then
yes he's in younger he plays the book
agent for every various there's only one
various talents there's only one they
are at a publishing company they need an
agent to work with he's great he
deserves more roles 100 where has he
been maybe if there's like a Matt Healy
biopic he could play him
um I like that call for you also you
know what I started last night Jewish
matchmaking I saw on your IG what do you
think well I really liked the initial
show called Indian matchmaking that I
thought really highlighted like
beautiful parts of Indian culture and
left Ben and I with like an immense
respect I feel like there's a lot of
like you know negativity when it comes
to arranged marriages they're so old
school but I don't know it really gave
me a fresh perspective on it and that's
why I felt confident watching the Jewish
one because matchmaking is a huge huge
part of Jewish culture it's not an
arranged marriage per se but it's there
are like a lot of professional women
whose job it is to be matchmakers so I
felt confident watching it because up
until this point everything I've seen
that it's even remotely like touches on
Judaism on Netflix is so honestly like
disgusting and offensive and and
borderline on not borderline untrue
um so I had not watched it but then
Brian called me he was like you will
love this show like the woman is amazing
and Jackie it's really good I heard it's
really good I've heard it represents all
different uh levels of Judaism Judaism
personalities within Judaism and is also
really respectful towards Judaism and so
maybe I will watch it and you know what
I liked is because like one of the
problems one of the shows on Netflix
that claims to represent like Jewish
culture is my unorthodox life and one of
the problems I had with it was that like
it really represented Orthodox Judaism
like really really misrepresented it
like there was so much um
you know talk about how women in that
Community like can't leave the house and
can't get jobs and and the Matchmaker
here is ultra Orthodox not Ultra
Orthodox she's she's Orthodox she lives
in Israel and she's like a business
owner she runs this very successful
matchmaking business her husband and her
are like so cute you would die from the
husband like he was vacuuming their lawn
like he's so cute and it just like that
really is what those communities are
like and like that's why I felt the my
own Orthodox life show to be so
inaccurate it's like I know a lot of
people who live in the community that
they're talking about Muncie we have
family who lives there they have jobs
like they start businesses they go to
school they get their degrees like it's
not this like it's like literally nobody
stop you from like leaving going on a
reality show and embarrassing yourself
like really stopping you right no it's
just it was so inaccurate and so I real
the woman in Elisa who's like the
Matchmaker oh my God she's so cute and
she reminds me so much of like all of
our teachers growing up she's literally
Miss shine van remember Miss shyman she
was your teacher she wasn't your teacher
maybe for like one class oh you missed
out Michelle I remember as my queen I
didn't have enough classes with her to
like identify with her as like my
teacher I think about her all the time I
would love to get in contact with her if
somehow this podcast makes sense I know
she lives in Israel now and she got
married so her name isn't Shine byn
Anymore she was like you know everyone
has a teacher who like really left like
a positive she was mine who's yours oh a
teacher who left also shout out to miss
bracho she still works at my high school
she was a queen hmm
were you not impacted by a teacher in a
positive way
nothing comes to mind but maybe all your
teachers were so great maybe I did
Bounce Around schools a little bit you
know you did that's actually so true so
I feel like I didn't get to have those
attachments oh that's that's hard that's
sad it is like I think so finally back
on so many of my teachers don't get me
wrong some of them I literally wouldn't
think twice before like slapping them in
the face but still being my teachers
like really shout out Miss bracho Dr
aharon you know a lot of them really I
guess maybe like more Middle School
teachers like Mr Levine well Mr Levine
was hot that's why he left a mark on us
he also like cared about
yeah he also tutored us yeah like he he
cared about our success I wouldn't say I
don't know that he cares about all
students as much as like he likes us
especially yeah I think he just like he
could see that we were girls yeah and I
I liked to think back in the day that he
took a special liking just because he
like thought we were pretty no no that's
not why and he actually does care about
all students because now he's the
principal yeah but he like I think it's
so important like when really telling
the story like don't forget how hot he
was yeah yeah and he was Jermaine and he
was like young and single which is like
not very common for teachers you know
especially our teachers were all like
older and tenured he was like this hot
young thing and he was like Israeli and
he like smoked cigarettes but he always
shoot them and he smelled like tobacco
and gum and it was like so hot
this episode will probably make its way
to him well I'm so glad to see him
climbing the ranks you know now being
the Headmaster getting to oversee more
campers right having like a great impact
no I like was obsessed I think that was
probably like my first crush now that I
think about it like before Maverick
because he
um yeah what did he teach us even Hebrew
he taught Hebrew but he tutored Us in
math math yeah he was like really smart
yeah
obsessed
oh my God not him having to like if this
okay by the way if this episode gets
back to all of our teachers which I know
it will because everyone on the planet
listens to this podcast like of course
it's the day I'm not wearing any makeup
maybe they'll just send if you are going
to send it around to the teachers just
send the podcast thanks
um and remember like that other time you
talked about a teacher and and then he
reached out yeah that that story is in
my book that story's in my book because
that was a good story oh really yeah
which one our English teacher from high
school yeah yeah
that's stories in my book but that's
like a that story like makes me want to
not do this job it's it's enough to quit
it's enough to quit yeah that's really
the trouble with this podcast like I
have gotta stop I know but but those
stories like the ones we just told like
that's what like that's what the
toasters love it is true but like you
guys don't know how we're putting like
our personal lives out on the line for
the show just imagine like you talk
about an old teacher and and say that
they're hot or whatever and then they
hear it and then they text you that they
hurt listen to your podcast like that's
my 13th reason like it's enough I can't
no but I do hope to hear from like Miss
Marco honestly if I could be reconnected
with my shine byn like you know the pro
there are pros and cons sometimes used
to talk about someone and they reach out
it's like oh my God I can't believe this
reads you when you get reconnected right
and that sometimes it's not and
sometimes it's not what did you say
about your English teacher no I can't I
can't get back into it read the book uh
girl with no job.com very fair
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know
like okay
today's episode is brought to you by
Urban stems Urban stems delivers modern
bouquets and stylish plants next day
Nationwide and with Mother's Day coming
up I just sent Jackie a gorgeous Urban
stems bouquet it's coming up it's on
Sunday you guys get your orders in put
it on the tape people because they're so
pretty we should have every bouquet is
designed in-house and they're super on
Trend and every delivery includes a
personalized note to your recipient
thoughtfully designed packaging this
note was so sweet it was I read it on
our Instagram stories check it out and
there's 100 happiness guarantee you can
schedule your flower delivery in advance
to show how much you love them and don't
wait until the last minute to settle for
disappointing store flowers from the
grocery store
you can shop on their website by price
by color or even flower type and you can
take your pick from a variety of
bouquets plants gifts and floral
subscriptions that are all available at
urbancemes.com Jax and I put together a
little you know curated list of our most
favorite and stunning Urban stems
bouquets so when you go to
urbanstems.com toast you will be
shopping from like our hands like it was
our hands who kind of put these bouquets
together you know yes it was our eye our
style our nose our heart oh that's
beautiful so Mother's Day is coming up
but it's also just never a bad time to
send someone flowers let someone know
you're thinking of them send this
podcast to your man and be like [__]
send me flowers Mother's Day is coming
up Sunday May 14th you can visit
urbanstems.com toast to see some of our
top picks just be sure to order in time
by using Code toast for 15 off your
purchase again that's code toast for 15
off your purchase at urbanstems.com
toast t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
brought to you by Lululemon the Align
collection so what we've been talking a
lot about the Align collection the pants
I wear every single day all day every
day I'm only not wearing them today
because I was told you shouldn't wear
leggings after a spray tan and that was
like information I had never heard it
makes sense I know so I did pack them
you know when we were in the leggings
right or the legs sure but the leggings
so the pants that I wear every day on
the toast are from Lululemon's align
collection they're called the high-rise
mini flare pant and they're just like a
like a yoga pant with like a sexy little
flare at the end they add a little
sophistication to the most mundane look
the little Pizzazz a little Razzle
Dazzle they're really flexible the
four-way stretch means that I can bend I
can stretch I can move any way I want to
without restriction they're really
comfortable because they're made with
nulu fabric for the softest comfiest
texture that my legs have ever felt the
fit is also great it shapes perfectly to
my body for a flattering look that's
Uniquely Yours also from the Align
collection I have the biker shorts I
think I have running shorts just things
that I can run errands in that I can lay
around in the house in and the granular
leggings that are not flare they come in
really pretty colors too like I got a
bunch of messages when I wore these like
mauve ones and yeah I did post an
affiliate links so check it out they're
also so soft and they're so comfortable
I've been wearing them throughout my
pregnancy and they conform to my new
shade right they're like very weightless
there's no like digging band in your
stomach no digging like sometimes I like
literally could get nauseous and a
stomach ache from certain pairs of pants
so get into the Lululemon align
collection at lululemon.com again the
pants that I always Rave about are
called the Lululemon align collection
they're called the high rise flare pant
but they have a bunch of different
options bunch of different colors I wear
them in Black because you know black is
my queen
thank you you're welcome are you ready
for our first story I am I'm curious I
feel like I don't even know what the
stories are today I'm feeling just I
feel like I'll feel a little familiar
okay you've probably seen them around
town there's some new stuff first you've
seen Morgan Wallen Reveals His diagnosis
as he cancels six more weeks of tour
dates
Morgan Wallen has canceled six more
weeks of tour dates after re-injuring
his vocal cords he took to his Instagram
on Tuesday afternoon to share the bad
news that he received on Monday after
visiting the Vanderbilt voice Center in
Nashville he said quote after taking 10
days of vocal rest I performed three
shows last weekend in Florida and by the
third one I felt terrible he said he was
advised to go on vocal rest for six
weeks and he's decided to follow
doctor's orders he said they want me to
not talk at all but they said if I need
to it's okay for something like this
because obviously he's talking in the
video
um so postponing six weeks of tour this
literally not to make it about me
couldn't be more have worked out worse
for me like he did three shows and
strained himself and it was like the
show I would have wanted to go to right
but if he had canceled before your show
would have been rescheduled in Florida
oh I couldn't wait I can't wait you
could have been pumping on the way
um yeah so I'm sorry to Morgan Wallen
his fans and his voice and to myself
yeah well I want to say like when I
first saw this I was like oh
I wasn't buying it like we talked about
this so at first when he canceled after
the openers went on and he made people
wait an hour right that OG show security
guard video said that Morgan was drunk
and that's why he canceled and then he
canceled a few more shows to like make
the LIE look real that he had lost his
voice we were do be skeptical we were
skeptical and when this thing came out I
was like oh please like something is
going on you know I'm a very well
connected person and I did like you know
inquire to a few with you to a few other
well-connected people and it appears as
though he's having major vocal trouble
like I just feel like he's so you know
he's troubled almost that anytime
something's even remotely awry I'm
automatically like well what's going on
he's drinking but I did inquire and
everything I've Been Told
appears to me that this is the truth I
believe him because I I don't think he
would cite like the Vanderbilt voice
Center if he didn't go there because you
know they would come out and be like we
I don't I don't know this man when
people well they can't because that's
like doctor confidentiality but like
when people like include so many details
I'm always like oh you're lying
but sometimes it's the details that give
it if they don't include any details and
it's so vague what's her face went to a
mental health facility Raquel even
though you know she actually did
what is it I don't know I don't know
what the facility is but there's a lot
of speculation about whether Raquel like
with her Instagram story statement
saying she was going to like get
treatment whether she was going to like
a spa Canyon Ranch or like an actual
like mental and
as far as I've heard she's in like a
like an actual like facility okay
I believe him I well I do too now that I
inquired because also like why would he
I guess like you could say you know he
missed those shows because he had been
drinking and then maybe he's taking six
weeks to like go to rehab but I don't
think so I don't think that
that he would do that I don't think his
management like he could have tour in
the tour yeah and they could just like
keep propping him up for the rest of the
tour I believe that his voice is shot
you know what's so interesting to me
I've been thinking about because like
we're in like the summer concert series
how pretty much like the four biggest
artists in the world right now like are
technically just based on tour Taylor
Beyonce her tour is about to start Luke
Holmes and Morgan Wallen isn't that
crazy those are the four artists playing
all the stadiums this summer there's not
other people who we just don't follow
and you don't know about like maybe play
no they do like those stadiums but all
over the world but okay fine like
Coldplay whatever I just feel like when
we think about the big artists we always
say Taylor we always say Beyonce we
always say Instagram it's like I don't
know if it um I see a picture of a
stadium I don't know if it's Luke or
Taylor right like they're like isn't it
so crazy and no one's talking about like
Luke Combs is playing the same venues as
Taylor Swift he's just so low-key he
doesn't need all these animals but like
nobody talks about how like
yeah that's a thing yeah I just was so
obsessed with Luke Combs album and
actually like I have to go out of my way
to listen to other music so that I can
like be educated and writing music
that's going on what's like a song from
the album that like At first wasn't you
know living giving to you and now it's
like you've listened to it so much that
it's really bringing on well I've really
been listening to my liked songs so it's
like the ones that I choose but the
other day I was listening to five leaf
clover and just hit me different again
no it hits different when he says who
would who could have wound up with weeds
like I'm not okay no it oh my god I
didn't even hear that part you know
because the whole the whole song I said
I I didn't even have to register like me
who could have end up with three you
wind up with a five-leaf clover and also
a guy like me who'd have been fine with
three okay so that's the that's the
lyric in the chorus but then at the last
chorus how a guy like me who could have
wound up with weeds wind up with a five
leaf let me tell you like the lyricism
like we all need to get into Luke Combs
like I'm really sick of this like I
don't like country but you know what I
don't like you
you know I'm really so over that like
people have just such like a a
misunderstanding of what like country
music is like and it's the same thing
with like Taylor people are always like
Taylor's like pop star like writes about
her boyfriend and it's not it's actually
like profound lyricism it's poetry and
really Luke combs's music is poetry yeah
and it's about time like we all started
[__] respecting it I'm sick of it I'm
sick
I mean we do I'm not talking about I
feel like we associate with people who
don't I'm not talking about us
you can only control yourself dirty low
Jackie listen to this lyric okay I've
already said it on the toes but it's one
that really stuck with me
some battles but no I'm sorry I [__]
it up some battles have fought on
foreign Shores
and some are fought behind closed doors
some Fall From Grace some lose their way
some find the peace salvation brings
like I'm not even a Christian
but I'm seeking salvation you are I am a
Christian she's not a Christian
she could be a Jew and believe in God
you're seeking salvation
Desperately Seeking salvation
no the whole album and some I have to
skip some because like they make me too
emotional I'm like I just say it can't
right now except I do up to I do have to
acknowledge like the one flop on the
album that I always Skip and you have a
skin and I just want to say I do this to
all my favorite artists Luke this is
nothing against you
but I do this to Taylor like there's
just one flop on the album I'll tell you
what mine is but what's yours there's a
fox in the head house it's like a song
all about hunting like I genuinely can't
relate to it I can't seem to get him out
but it's honestly like I feel like if
you're into hunting or you live on a
farm and you know what it's like to have
a fox like plague there was a fox on
Brian's Farm and it was killing all the
animals like a fox it's like it's like
having lice it's like the worst plague
so it's like it's redneck imagery you
know so there are a lot of people who
can relate to it and it's like all about
like sneaking up on the fox and just
like trying to kill the fox
but let me tell you like I just have to
skip the song
it's not on my like so I don't listen to
it that much but my skip is the hottest
take of all time
I think I've told you this what is it
fast car
oh my God you're not okay for those who
don't know Luke Combs you to cover on
his album a fast car the Tracy Chapman
song it's like a song that he's like
covered in bars like before he got
famous and there's so many videos of him
on the internet doing it and people
loved it so much and he explained this
weekend actually why the song is so
important to him like his dad introduced
him to it and his dad used to play the
cassette yada yada
um I cannot believe like like I'm
vomiting and I'm like this isn't Luke
okay here like it's not like it's I
don't like it because it's not Luke
Combs and I don't even like I didn't
love this the song I never thought about
the song before but it's just like not
my favorite song at all and I'm just
like I want to hear what Luke has to say
I want to hear what Luke thinks let me
offer a different perspective I want you
because the song is all about you know
getting out of town like you and your
girl we got a car let's just get out of
here
pronouns are off in the song like he's
singing from a female perspective but I
do want to I want to
um pull up the lyric where the pronouns
are off just because like that's where I
kind of get stuck
okay
my bad my bad my bad okay okay Fast Car
lyrics
and then you have to get over you have
to get over the pronoun thing no no it's
not what's hanging me up completely like
um I'm just saying it's just always
something that I noticed well sorry the
point before you got into that Jackie
the point that I was trying to make is
like I want you to actually listen to
the song because it's not what you think
like it's about okay you need to listen
to the whole song it's actually like a
sad song
okay okay okay I'll listen okay
but it's not about like the words that
are bothering me it's just like
it's just not loopy enough where Did We
Go From Here Morgan Morgan Wallen um
rest up morgie rest up that's really
scary because like is there a situation
where your voice doesn't come back like
no but there are a few artists who have
had to get that surgery Adele got it
John Mayer got it it's like the vocal
nodes it's a really scary surgery
especially if you're like a singer
there's an episode of Glee where Lea
Michele has it
um
but I don't think unless they botch it I
don't know
um
okay well I hope that he takes the time
that he needs yeah you know I saw clips
from like his final show in Florida and
like it was bad oh yeah like the voice
was not voicing Okay so
speaks to the truth of this of the
matter I believe it yeah be ready for
our next story yeah
Robert De Niro is okay and good with
welcoming baby number seven at 79. so at
the New York premiere of his most recent
film about my father on Tuesday the
Oscar winner told extra that um he
recently welcomed a seventh baby he said
that I'm okay with it I'm good with it
that's just what a baby wants to hear
though he added it never gets easier
because when he sat down with 18 Canada
for an interview about this movie they
were talking about his six children and
he said seven actually oh that's how it
was known that he fathered a seventh
child he sired a seventh child so
biblical
who's the mom um so then Kim Cattrall
said that he welcomed the seventh child
that's his co-star in this movie with
his rumored girlfriend Tiffany Chen how
old is she
give me a second because I know like
wealthy people have access to like you
know insane Medical Care and stuff but
like he's literally 64. what
no
hmm
one second let me just make sure it's
the right biblical person
it's giving Abraham and Sarah
what is she she had a baby what when she
was 102 or something yeah
it's unclear a quick Google said 64 but
maybe it's not um
Tiffany who is Robert De Niro's
girlfriend Tiffany Chen thank you Daily
Mail
is there a photo
yeah does she look 65. she's wearing a
mask
so tough to tell yeah
I don't think she's 64. let me see a
picture
I think she's 64.
no for y'all like what are you looking
at
um and that makes me like Robert De Niro
he's dating someone age-appropriate I
don't think she's let me see let me say
this
she's wearing a mask in every photo
maybe it's a pandemic relationship
I just don't think that the like their
people have enough information about
them as a couple so they're like grass
man straws yeah no I'm sorry like us
right now I actually feel like she could
be 65. I don't know no I I the woman
that I grew like that's not her oh okay
okay
yeah interesting
well happy for you Robert you know
it's amazing I don't know what to say
I'm glad that he's good with it though
yeah no I'm not I'm glad he's okay with
it I'm glad he's feeling fine about his
new baby yeah I can't wait for the baby
to grow up and watch that yeah I don't
know Kim Cattrall was like doing Robert
De Niro flicks yeah I know and feeling
the beans happy for her
Tiffany's a martial arts instructor
oh maybe that's why she looks so young
yeah or maybe that's like why she's not
64. right right interesting I wonder
where they met maybe he was taking
martial arts class
yeah there's not a lot of info about
them as a couple which is why I think
people are really quaking about
um him having a baby and also maybe like
spilling the beans he was like married
for a really long time yes to a woman
named Claudia correct
um yes or at one point he was in a
relationship but he was also married to
a woman named Grace
he met Tiffany when they were filming a
movie together in 2015. oh what she was
like the special martial artist like
producer on set yeah cool very cool so
it's giving you like Nick Cannon energy
yeah Elon Musk they should all get
together right they should get the kids
together
and like start a football team like rent
out Six Flags literally
so that's really sweet yeah it's nice
it's nice I'm happy for them are you
ready for our next story is it the next
story that's brought to you by Thrive
Cosmetics it is
all right you guys Thrive Cosmetics I
first learned about on social media from
a lot of you guys and now it is my go-to
cosmetic brand especially their mascara
so that's probably like their most
popular product and how I was introduced
to the brand and now I use a lot of
their different products like the lip
tints the eyeliner but my first love
when it comes to thrive Cosmetics is
this liquid lash extensions mascara if
you've watched any sort of like makeup
tutorial I've done over the last five
years all I do is talk about my lashes
like they're long but they are so
straight you would never know how long
they are and they don't hold a curl and
then I accidentally burn them off like
in a traumatic trip to Utah a few years
ago
and somebody told me about the liquid
lash extensions mascara from Thrive
cosmetics and it is really like I wear
it on red carpets I wear it every day on
the toast it is really like that [__]
you know they have more than 25 000 star
reviews for this mascara it mimics the
look of lash extensions but it doesn't
have the damaging glue or the salon
pricing they use a proprietary tubing
formula which means that it basically
wraps around each lash as you apply it
to dramatically lengthen and Define your
lashes from root to tip it lasts all day
without clumping without smudging or
flaking I can attest to that by the time
I take it off like it's not moving it
nourishes um it has nourishing
ingredients that support longer stronger
and healthier looking lashes over time
it's really easy to remove I have used
waterproof mascara in the past that's
literally like cement on your lashes
this mascara comes off with just regular
makeup remover it's fabulous I also
really like their waterproof eyeliner it
is waterproof and smudge proof so you
can cry in it you know if you're
watching an episode of the toast
laughing so hard like you're good the
hydrating lip tints we both wear on the
toast a lot of days it has a nice really
pretty tint to it but it's super
hydrating and there's no mirror needed
it has an effortless applicator it
Glides on really smooth it has that
lightweight balmy non-sticky formula
that hydrates your lips to make them
smoother so you can try Thrive Cosmetics
to see for yourself right now you can
get an exclusive 15 off your first order
when you visit thrivecosmetics.com toast
that's Thrive
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast
for 15 off your order today's episode is
also brought to you by Topgolf it's golf
it's not golf it's Topgolf I'm so glad
to be talking about Topgolf because as
you know any excuse for you to talk
about your time at Topgolf guys and any
excuse for me to say it's golf it's not
golf it's Topgolf but after having been
there again this weekend it is Golf and
it is not golf and it is TopGolf and I
found out who the quarterback was the
guy remember I told you that you draft
the quarterback draft for the Tennessee
Titans like a really big deal I saw it
on Instagram today Topgolf posted
because they were excited so Topgolf is
a great way to spend the night maybe
you'll run into someone famous no
promises though it's a gorgeous way to
spend girls night guys night couples
couples night any kind of night great
food great drinks and that's the fun so
you know that's the not golf part but
the golf part is actually really fun
they have this super fun game you don't
have to be like a golf expert but if you
are a golf expert I guess you can come
and like embarrass all the girls annoy
everyone
um so the stuff that makes them golf is
like the clubs the balls the t's the
turf the ball picker upper um but
there's a bunch of stuff that's knocked
off like great music giant Targets in
the Fairway huge TVs handcrafted food
and beverage menu I had the best time I
ate so much ben ate so much the food was
so good they did like the people who
worked there were so nice they did like
a cute little birthday thing with for
our friend Pete it was really fun and
they also um have half price Tuesday
it's a promotion that full terms can be
found at topgolf.com Tuesday but great
way to spend your Tuesday it's golf it's
not golf it's Topgolf Pro tip download
the app and book ahead of time to come
play around on half price Tuesday or any
other day the bays are heated in the
winter cooled in the summer you'll
always be temperature conscious get some
food grab grab your gals and just have
fun it's a great place to meet people
too
it is thank you Claudia you're welcome I
found the lyric that was bothering you
you got a fast car we go cruising
entertain ourselves you still ain't got
a job and I work in the market as a
checkout girl
oh so Luke says I work in the market as
a checkout
yeah you know I guess he does I
literally never noticed it it doesn't
bother me in the slightest
Jackie's not okay Jack is that okay it's
like actually more Stark than I even
thought
no actually I think he changes it so you
work in the market as a checkout girl
I'm pretty sure Luke changed it you
think yeah
I'm like pretty positive
so you work in the market as a checkout
girl we'll have to listen I got a job
loves to listen it's Luke's version is
different
fast car Luke's version
yeah I'm pretty sure it doesn't have
that lyric but go off can you imagine
that it does Jackie's cackling his
cheers
are you ready for our next story I am
some lovely love news yeah Sia is
married to Dan Bernard So Random the
Australian pop Superstar wed Dan Bernard
and intermittent intimate ceremony at
Villa olivetta the home of designers uh
Stefano Dolce and Dominico Gabbana in
Portofino Italy on Monday I know what
it's so funny because she is like such a
Kardashian girl yeah and she got married
at the same place as Courtney yeah but
the Kardashians weren't there I mean it
was really small yeah yeah yeah and I
don't think they're like that close no
they are that close like Sia wasn't at
Courtney's wedding was she was she I
don't think so you would know if you
watched the thing so would I yeah I
didn't watch the special photos obtain
my page page six showed the bride
wearing a light pink lace embroidered
fishtail ground which featured a high
neckline and long sleeves also I feel
like she's definitely super close with
Kim and Chloe and Chris I don't know if
she's as close with Courtney that's true
um but like she's always around and
she's always face timing and sending
love yeah no she's performing at every
small intimate Affair that they host
yeah like North's birthday I'll be there
yeah yeah yeah uh I love Sia we got some
aerial photos of the nuptials who's her
man Dan Bernard who's that Dan Bernard
you say that like it's Cher like who's
Dan Bernard
Claudia it's Dan Bernard got it okay no
nobody knew who he was before now
um and now we know that it is Dan
Bernard it is
yeah okay because I had thought that it
was someone else much like Tiffany Chen
there's not a lot of information about
Dan bernardia lives a very low-key life
even though she does perform at you know
the biannual Kardashian events she
really does live like this very quiet
simple life yeah so now she's Mrs
Bernard Sia Bernard
gorgeous it's got a nice ring to it yeah
like I just love her me too she's really
a queen and when are we getting to see a
music
there was a time period where it was
like Banger Banger Banger from SIA you
know chandelier electric Elastic Heart
That album was just like a gasoline
um
like where's Sia I feel like she does
like do songs collabs and stuff but
collabs yeah but like she hasn't done
like a last album in a while she did
give us Candy Cane Lane so honestly she
doesn't really need to do anything after
that I will genuinely like never not
start laughing when I hear Candy Cane
Lane I know but you know it's like
become such a big holiday song it's not
even just for us I wasn't speaking about
that like because it's a bad song I
think it's like the best holiday song
like we would like that no one would
ever have heard of but it's in every
holiday movie like she has licensed the
[__] out of it and she's like I just
made this holiday song for you guys like
please enjoy it there are a few modern
holiday songs which have made it into
the classics Kelly Clarkson's
underneath the tree like that one made
it all I want for Christmas it misses
you yeah but I um I only I laugh at
Candy Cane Lane because it's actually
pure of course you guys
we were on vacation in Utah and we were
like staying in a house and we decided
to go to a hotel for dinner so we got
like this big like van to come pick us
up and we ate dinner and like the meal
like wasn't great and like we had like
drank but like it was like not the night
like wasn't you guys were awesome The
Vibes were all of them was also really
hot the Batman was wearing sweaters
because it was snow season yeah so we
get back in the band for some reason
Shapiro like sat in the back which he
just shouldn't have because he gets
overheated and I sat in the front on the
ox yeah of course and she appears like
in the back of the van like wanting to
kill us like maybe he's just like been
on vacation with us for too long and
he's like done with us and he was like
so hot and the air conditioning was like
in his defense like not reaching him in
the back and he does not you know he
does not deal with overheating well I
mean who does and we're like in the
front of the van like we don't he's like
screaming for the air he's like please
put the air on we're not listening
because the oxes take a trip down Candy
Cane Lane with me and he's like
screaming and we can't hear him and he
just gets so mad and he will not listen
to Candy Cane Lane anymore like it's a
triggering song for him back to that
moment where he was kind of like
voiceless he was silenced yeah but it's
so funny and the song is so good so good
take a trip down Candy Cane Lane with me
so good
are you ready for our next story yeah
something that I think you might find
interesting because Luanda seps has set
her sights on Kevin Costner amid his
divorce
me when I'm delusional so
Luanne was at um the premiere of book
club the next chapter of course she was
Monday evening I just want to say I was
going to text my book club that we
should go see that movie I didn't see
the first one though like yeah you
should see the first one I just wanted
to be like a fun outing for the book
club yeah that right
um and she was asked about her dating
life and she said Kevin Costner he's so
elegant he's my type at the Oscars
didn't you think he was amazing his
speech he was so elegant so eloquent so
manly I'm sorry like um there is nothing
this woman could do to make me dislike
her like Luanda steps is low-key the
funniest [__] on the planet like I know
she wasn't even trying to be funny here
but like it's hysterical and you know
what I ship crazier things have happened
I ship wholeheartedly I mean let me not
forget this woman is like formally a
royal like Aristocrat like she has a
pedigree Kevin Costner could do a lot
worse no 100 she's a gorgeous woman I
feel like it's not out of the realm of
possibility no it's like not
and I am like she has my full support no
I actually have my support like she has
my maybe we need to like book them on
the toast like back to back they'll meet
right here love and they can take it
from there
she's honestly like Andy should have
them on watch live together like
everyone needs to do their part that's
actually a good idea like that's how
they made yeah
everyone needs to do their part to get
Luanne
yeah
because I was gonna say Luanne Costner
doesn't like roll off the tongue but
like she would literally go from being
like a British royal to being American
royalty like being the girlfriend wife
of Yellowstone John Dutton like that
that seems like how her story ends
honestly like I could see it I could see
it too no that's why I was drawn to the
story
I'm upset things that make sense yeah
and they kind of look alike you know
when people are meant to be like they do
sort of look alike yeah
they do yeah they could start I I mean I
I seriously see it and then perhaps like
she's the motivation he needs to get
back to work at Yellowstone and then of
course he's so grateful to her for you
know her helping him see the light he
writes a role for her where she's like a
ranch hand or something who does Cabaret
on the side like the story pretty much
writes itself it does I'm exhaust it's
not far-fetched it's not
so we'll keep you posted on that yeah on
budding romance spottings sightings
our fifth and final story is the
crossover news that nobody asked for
okay I'm really excited to get your
thoughts on this okay the Jonas Brothers
can give you directions as the new
voices of the navigation app what is the
Jonas brothers are giving ways users the
wings they need to fly and drive with
their latest collab on Wednesday Waze
announced that Kevin Nick and Joe will
be the next Celebrity Driving
instructors through the new drive with
Jonas experience available now the
brothers voice instructions some of
which can be heard in an Instagram
teaser will leave fans entertained on
their daily commutes through witty
directions and tour life anecdotes the
brother said in a statement growing up
on the road our tour bus became our home
away from home so we know the importance
of getting places safely and on time
nothing like trying to make a connection
for why they do this brand deal like we
get them they beat you and it's like fun
and quirky we don't need like an
anecdote from Tor if users happen to
find themselves in the Jonas Brothers
home state of New Jersey they'll also
get some tailored tips like exit right
and if you happen to be on New Jersey
Route 3 don't miss The Tick Tock Diner
in Clifton that really feels like like a
way to get lost
they also will be sharing memories like
you've arrived congrats as a reward I
will tell you about the most ridiculous
show we have ever played
foreign
IST I would never recommend like my
client do this I feel like being the
voice of a GPS is like a fast track to
becoming the most hated person on the
planet I [__] hate that [__] Siri
who's like first of all she's always
pausing my music I'm like I could see
the map I don't need you to tell me like
she's always like [__] me up I feel
like I have like a very contentious
relationship with the GPS voice so I
wouldn't want to be that voice because
then people would just hate me yeah but
you don't think that this is maybe a way
to mend ties between GPS voice and
driver and that maybe we could all get
along like I think that the hope is that
the person who gets in the car would
listen to the GPS voice and the GPS
voice only but most people have GPS and
like podcasts GPS and music and the GPS
always just becomes like a nuisance but
I guess it's cool if you're doing GPS
and listening to the Jonas Brothers and
it's like okay you have to be
interrupted for your direction but it's
a brethren yeah that would be like us
doing GPS voices while you listen to the
toast yeah
I'm just saying like that is a good idea
yeah if they had multiple artists so
it's like you will be interrupted by the
person that you are listening to I just
I don't think I would do it what if you
were interrupted by Luke and he's like
hey Turtle honestly like there's a fox
in the hen house turn right
no my name is Taylor I still think I
would find it annoying like there's just
something about the GPS voice that no
matter who it is and I know it's
pre-recorded it's like not even
pre-recorded it's AI like I would find
it annoying I would be like shut up I
think that if they could find a way to
have like every artist in the system and
when you're listening to that artist
that person that's a good idea is a
better idea you know it's more seamless
that's maybe this is the start of that
like that's pretty like creative yeah
but I don't know
I don't know either
it's a little weird
yeah it's not like the I like the thing
that we needed that the next step for
civilization Jonas Brothers doing
navigation this is like a cute brand
deal like let's not let's you know call
a space do you use Waze is that your
navigation of choice no
me neither what do you use uh Apple Maps
I think okay like my inclination is like
always like Apple Maps Ben is like so
against Apple Maps why if I ever like if
we're going somewhere he's like how long
does it say I'm like 30 minutes he's
like what are you using he only uses
Google I don't use Google Maps and then
when I have like I find the place on
Google on Safari and then they like want
me to download Google Maps I'm like no I
actually really like Apple Maps I think
it's fine and someone bought ways and
ruined it who was that Google yes yeah
yeah because ways used to be the best
and now ways is the worst no Waze is
fine for me like everybody like it's
they were directing you towards traffic
they're directing all the people to use
the same streets because there's the
same small street that like wasn't built
for this amount of traffic it's tough
because we're in the city and it's like
the Trap traffic in the city is like
actually
unpredictable like no app is Gonna Save
Us yeah but I think if I were like out
and you know the country I would be
comfortable using Waze I feel
comfortable using Apple maps in everyday
life I like Apple Maps too and these
days I use Tesla map in my car but you
know apple has a way of like destroying
everything you know Apple the Apple
weather app was always like Beyond trash
and then they bought dark sky Ben's
favorite website and now they shut down
darkseid.com and made their app like
dark sky and it sucks it's like Airbnb
and luxury Retreats right like
everyone's just like snatching up their
competitors and making them and ruining
it yeah and making it worse ruin I don't
mind you want to snatch up and you want
to capitalize sure sure but then they
shut it down and they fold it into the
bigger company which is trash I agree
now it's like Airbnb Lux and it's just
Airbnb it's just Airbnb yeah no it's our
life is so hard
nobody gets uh nobody does like we make
this life Jonas Brothers Are Gonna Get
Us on our way
sure
so those are the best five feel as
though you need to know them
feels though also you know I feel like
this week I'm just like kind of like
talking out of my ass and like saying
things that are not true like like
yesterday when I said the Knicks lost
and they're out there's another game I'm
happy about that you know I'm glad that
you said that they lost in their outside
was sad and then I got to be
yeah opposed to the opposite you know
yeah
so I'm sorry I'm just like I'm I gotta
stop saying stuff like but that's your
job I know
you know it is what it is yeah so we
have to your toasters today the show is
not even over yet which is so exciting
deer toasters is our weekly advice
segment so every Wednesday we do a
little three submissions you can email
us steer toasters gmail.com if you have
written in and we haven't read your
response yet either it sucks or it's too
long so feel free to write in again but
like a more Abridged version just need
to know details
um and if we've given you advice like
we've read your submission on air the
last couple of weeks or months please
feel free to write Us in with an update
as to what happened today we do have an
update which is very exciting I know I'm
so happy for you yeah for me yeah
because you love the updates so invested
no I do but I think you love them more I
would say we love them equally oh okay
okay yeah sure sure I love them so much
no I do but you'll get so excited about
them yeah of course because it's like
it's the fruits of our labor you know
yeah it's our results coming to life
yeah I just like to think that if I
don't get an update like everybody is
living peacefully right it's like you
only write a Yelp review when things go
bad like right so if I never get an
updated doesn't upset me because I'm
like amazing problem solved yeah I guess
it works to prosper
right I guess and you know getting an
update can lead to more problems which I
believe I haven't spoiled it yet but I
believe we have like a kind of a sad
update today oh yeah like I don't think
it's a happiest update we haven't had
one yet a sid update
things were going so well today I know
I'm sorry well your toasters is brought
to you by Squarespace
it is brought to you by Squarespace and
we love Squarespace and honestly for
some of you dear toaster Squarespace
could be the solution that you need if
you need if your problem has to do with
starting your own business and not
knowing where to start Squarespace is
everything to sell anything Squarespace
has the tools you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace is merchandising features to
make your products look their best
online so if you want a free trial um
head over to squarespace.com toast and
when you're ready to launch use offer
code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase for a website or a domain now
whatever you'd be starting a website for
whether it's a side hustle a Blog
Squarespace has so many different tools
that you can use to really highlight
your business and make your website as
seamless as possible so from e-commerce
to videoblocks if you want to connect
your social media accounts you'll get
really good insight into your traffic
overview so you'll see how your visits
unique visitors page views Etc Trend
over time you can gain insight into the
top traffic sources products device
types browsers operating systems Etc
also one of the best parts about
Squarespace is the content ownership so
you own all the content that you put on
your Squarespace platform they offer a
one-click data portability so again if
you want to check out squarespace.com
toast you will get a free trial and then
when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast you'll get 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
again that's squarespace.com toast the
offer code is toast when you're ready to
launch if you want to buy a domain
they'll help you get your domain set up
whether you want you know claudia.com
which you can't have because I have it
but whatever the domain that you want is
they'll help you get set up from start
to finish soup to not to squarespace.com
toast is here for you today's episode is
also brought to you by betterhelp think
you better help for sponsoring today's
episode it's so easy to get caught up in
what everyone else needs from you and
not take a moment to think about what
you need from yourself I feel like
sometimes I'm just like doing the most
for everyone and never being like what
does turdy want what does turdy need
what does turdy need when we spend all
of our time giving it can leave us
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy can help give you the tools to
find more balance in your life so you
can keep supporting others but without
leaving yourself behind if you've been
thinking of starting therapy why don't
you give better help a try it's a really
accessible platform it's all done
entirely online it's designed to be
really convenient really flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and of course you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge it being done entirely
online takes away a lot of those like
awkward social elements of traditional
therapy that I think block a lot of
people from pursuing it if you don't
like the the first therapist you're
matched with which is totally common and
totally normal it's all done online so
you just switch it up it's not awkward
it's not weird it's actually so easy
you can find more balance with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com toast
today to get 10 off your first month
again it's done entirely online so you
can talk to your therapist via video
chat phone call text whatever method
you're most comfortable with better Hub
will adjust to you super affordable it's
really accessible and again visit
betterhelp.com toast to get 10 off your
first month that's better help.com toast
new tagline better help what is turdy
knees yeah that works for me
all right are you ready you're so giggly
today I am ready for deer toasters uh
yeah I was saying I am giggling today
but I am also ready no I know oh cool I
asked two questions and you answer twice
what's wrong with that ready yeah I am
laughs
okay
good to go
good so much okay
hi Jackson Claude I was helping my
boyfriend of two and a half years clean
out his car before trading it in I
decided to tackle the glove box while he
washed the outside oh my gosh are you
okay I'm just lost in it yeah like have
you seen you actually sent me that Meme
of what it looks like for a baby in the
belly while my mother's laughing and
it's like the whole uh shaking thing
it's like but I think it's fine right no
yeah okay cheers no no I'm fine oh do I
actually have tears no it wasn't like a
concerning video it was like really cute
yeah it was cute but it's like it's fine
right yeah yeah no there was nothing
about it that was like don't laugh right
right attorney Lou doesn't laugh
I'd have to quit my job I actually wish
I was wearing that thrive Market
mascara today because this mascara that
I wear is horrible oh but do you not
have one here you should just get one no
I don't have one here that's why I had
to buy horrible I also need like a new
one mine's a little like empty okay I
place an order after this I want to give
a full attention Okay start again hi
Jackson Claude I was helping my
boyfriend of two and a half years clean
out his car before trading it in I
decided to tackle the glove box while he
washed the outside in between 12 years
of service receipts I found his vows
from his previous marriage he was
married for under a year she cheated he
moved on clean divorce no big deal this
is her husband or her boyfriend of two
and a half years but still the vows he
claims he had no idea they were in there
which I totally believe but still it's
not sitting right I love him to death
and we've even started looking at
engagement rings should I just move on
from this myth mishap thanks in advance
yeah like I don't think you keep
important really sentimental things in
your glove box like he probably shoved
them in there after the wedding and
really forgot about them yeah I'm going
to choose to believe him like yeah it
could be nefarious to get to his car
every day and like read some and jerks
off yeah but I don't think he does that
I
I think that he's really didn't know
they were in there I also did you find a
lot of other crap in there like is that
somewhere he throws his crap yeah she
said literally service receipts like so
that's how important it is to him as
important as a service receipt I'd also
like to offer a rebuttal really quickly
like if he had kept them for sentimental
purposes like
know and a lot of people have like a box
of like old photographs love letters
like I don't think that necessarily
means anything it's like it's your
history he was married I think keeping
them in a box that you don't see every
that you barely see ever is fine too it
is part of your personal history I think
the fact that they were in his car which
he uses every day it's like if you put
them in there intentionally it's because
he wants them close to him to him but
like a glove box is really like a
garbage yeah I don't think it means
anything and I also don't think that he
has to throw away his vows me neither
like I think it's actually like I mean
he shouldn't hang them on the fridge no
but like to have a box of like things
you accumulate in your life like from
old boyfriends like yeah it's like it's
weird for like the girlfriend to find it
but like Everyone's entitled to like a
little love box I I completely agree I
don't have one but like if I did it
would be cute yeah but you don't have
anything that Maverick gave you no
actually do have a love box but I think
it's so lost yeah but that's the point
it should get lost yeah when you move or
something you find right and it comes
with you from place to place it's not
like so important it's not something
that sits in Pride of place on your
mantel no but like my lovebox I've only
had one boyfriend so it's all from Ben
like it should sit on my mantel you know
she true I don't really don't have
anything for Maverick or Mr Levine
unfortunately you should put a cigarette
in there and a piece of gum
literally
we're being so funny today
ready ready hey girlies first off thanks
for being my daily break where I can sit
enjoy and laugh while I listen to your
gorgeous voices not faces notice how she
said
she probably doesn't watch on YouTube
yeah okay here's my issue my husband is
a great guy a fantastic father but a
shitty husband we celebrated our five
year marriage anniversary last Saturday
and he was responsible for making
reservations at a nice restaurant we've
never been to but he dropped the ball
didn't make the reservation and they
were fully booked we ended up having a
nice time in a regular spot and it was
lovely but boring I'm sick of his
[__] he's never excited about going
out it's like a chore to him and makes
me feel like I'm a chore to him too we
dated six years before we were married
and we never liked celebrating
anniversaries but I do and I think he
should act accordingly I want to be
cherished just like I cherish him now
I'm annoyed and I can't get over it am I
overreacting should I lower my standards
since I knew he was like this before we
were married love a sad burnt piece of
toast no like I feel like okay you maybe
you're not in the habit of doing like
big things for these Milestones so you
can't necessarily like blame him for not
you know renting out Central Park for
you but I feel like if you just vocalize
it and be like moving forward like I
want to be that type of couple I'm like
get on it it's your job goodbye you
can't be mad at him until he knows yes
but I also feel like anniversaries are
important to you they're not important
to him and they never were so he
shouldn't be in charge of planning
anniversaries you're kind of setting
yourself up for disappointment because
he might not even like have the
imagination to think of something that
would be really special for you for your
anniversary like he thinks oh dinner at
our place that we like for dinner like
and I know that we really lowered the
bar for men sometimes here on the show
and like but I feel like sometimes when
you set it too high you're just going to
be disappointed so like maybe keep it
low and that way you don't experience
like this is Disappointment you would
have made the reservation at a
restaurant that you really liked and you
guys would have had a nice time and like
Yeah it's annoying that you have to do
everything but delegate something else I
don't think that you should delegate
this but I do understand wanting to feel
special and for your anniversary like
but maybe there are other strengths of
his where he could shine in this
department you know what I mean like
maybe he's a good masseuse and I give
you a massage I think you're being
really realistic but like I refuse to
believe that like even husbands can't
plan anniversary dinners like I'm not
lowering the bar that low for her just I
think that he could plan an anniversary
dinner and yeah they wound up at their
local spot he thinks that that's nice
enough I think if you sit him down
say listen I know we haven't been like
very sentimental in the past but like
I've started to realize like we're
getting older we have kids like we
should take these nights off for
ourselves and I would like for you to
plan them say it in a really nice way
and if he doesn't do it after that be
like okay you're [__] useless I'll do
it and it's just not special enough
that's what I'm saying I don't know if
he's capable of Imagining the
specialness that you are imagining so
maybe you could even say like well you
could drop hints or you could be like
when it's our anniversary or it's a
special day like I would like to receive
flowers yeah you know urbandems.com
girls picked out some really gorgeous
designs yep but I'm being I'm serious or
it's like or I want a little gift or I
want a gift card to I think you need to
be really specific otherwise he can't
imagine what you're imagining and you're
just gonna be like disappointed and it
sounds like he's otherwise a really
great guy so let's work with what we've
got let's work with them yeah no
Jackie's being like hella realistic it's
just like so pathetic these men like my
God no and you make the reservation at
the restaurant of your dreams and he's
paying right right that's actually a
really good point you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah so a little compromise a
little balance a little bit marriage is
a compromise you know lest we not forget
yeah all right our third and final
submission is actually an update so I'm
gonna read you guys the original
submission from this girly
um and then we'll hear her update so her
original submission was I'm gonna need
some help I recently got engaged to a
total P John however I don't love my
engagement ring it's white gold and I'm
really just like a gold girly through
and through I have no idea why he picked
something other than gold since it's all
I wear in jewelry like I don't think I
own a silver piece at all I'm
contemplating getting a gold-plated
because this white gold just isn't me it
actually bugs me that he did this
because he hasn't been paying attention
or he hasn't been picked up on the fact
that I'm with gold jewelryware and we've
been together for seven years what do I
do am I being a [__] am I Justified for
wanting to make this ring perfect I love
the cut and everything else it's just
strictly the color and what we told her
was like you know to expect your man to
notice that you wear gold or silver
jewelry is like a little delusional
you want to get just like if everything
if the diamond itself is good and the
you just don't like the band or the
plating in terms of cost it's a much
lower cost and like oh I didn't like the
cut or the carrot of the diamond we were
just like change it like and you don't
need to be like bitter about it
it doesn't mean that he doesn't pay
attention to you I think when most men
walk into a jewelry store like the
typical engagement ring is silver yeah
and so he was actually so true he went
with you know what traditionally not
like oh she likes gold men are blind
like they have no idea they don't even
know these are two different colors like
no 100 it's not offensive but if you
don't want to wear it every day take
matters into your own hands but nothing
to write home about so here's her update
hi again girlies this is an update I've
been dreading to submit I was the girl
who got engaged last Christmas and was
not in love with her engagement ring
specifically the color of the band while
I'm crying as I type this but I've
chosen to call off my engagement not
because of this situation I never even
brought it up but because I found out my
fiance was hurting hiding certain things
and lying to my face we cannot be
engaged since he is not ready for
marriage if he's continuing to lie to
his fiance over and over so now I'm so
heartbroken we still live together but
I've been staying at my family or
friend's house but this is the worst
thing I've ever had to go through my
life flipped upside down and I don't
know how to move on since we were
together for seven years any advice
helps
you know what
this is like the most annoying like
Grandma thing to say while this is like
I'm short immensely painful right now
think about how much worse it could have
been if you had actually married this
person and realized like that he was
lying or that it wasn't a match and you
had to undo like a marriage and a
divorce maybe even you had kids at this
point like the fact that you got out
when you did and you guys realized you
weren't right for each other like it's
such a blessing and I would just be
grateful for that like think about how
much worse the situation could be if
this happened one year later like maybe
you're pregnant
maybe you were all like you guys got
married and things got worse like just
be grateful like you'll go through
heartbreak it's a healing Journey
everybody goes through it and then you
go out into the world and you meet
someone even better who would never lie
to you you know what that I feel I feel
good about the fact that you didn't get
married and I think it's like better to
call off an engagement than to get
divorced agreed and that's great advice
honestly I don't have anything to add on
top of that you can hit the nail on the
head and I'm sorry you're sad if I could
recommend some podcasts you know the
toast good guys probably a podcast mood
get some Giggles you know yeah and just
hold up like it's okay you don't feel
like you have to get back out there
right now like a seven year relationship
is [__] long take your time this too
shall pass it will all one day like be
in the rear view and you'll be like
thinking you'll be in a better situation
and so happy thinking about how you
dodged a bullet and just think about
that girl yeah and there's no
expectation that you need to be her
right now but just know that that's all
waiting for you this is one of the
situations where like you go through it
and it's so horrible but like you're
gonna be like 90 years old looking back
on your life and being like imagine if I
had gotten married or imagine if this
situation had worked out differently so
you know what God works in mysterious
ways but like you're struggling right
now but this is probably the best thing
to ever happen to I think you get to
keep the ring good question she didn't
even like it yeah give it back
um again dear toasters gmail.com is the
email that you can submit either your
submissions or an update if you have one
for us thank you to everyone who is
vulnerable with us and this is a safe
space for toasters and
that's really all she wrote that's that
on that turdy Lou has to head to Dallas
needs thank you guys so much for
listening to the Joseph Millennium
morning show tomorrow's episode is
podcast only so make sure you're
subscribed wherever you get your podcast
Friday there is no episode thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories 18 tonight
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so at Spotify iTunes
digital public radio I have Radio cast
box all the places so I will send a
podcast find us the toast leave a five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow love ya bye